oh there's no Jedi's in this one Shh
never mind
[Applause]
[Music]
the mandalorian first episode of it at
any rate I make no promises of keeping
up with episode by episode reviews of
this thing I really don't do episode by
episode reviews for anything other than
Doctor Who anymore and it's a pain in
the butt for me to have to operate on
the release schedule of a show rather
than get to work the schedule is I have
to set it so no promises on that if I
stick with it I will probably give a
wrap up once the seasons done airing but
for now this is just my impression and
my feelings on the first episode and
they are a bit mixed I will say this
there's nothing that I find to be a
glaring issue there's no fundamental oh
god this like like some of the problems
that I had with the last Jedi and nor
does it feel quite as overly workshopped
to death the way that solo did that said
it does have some of the flavor of some
of the issues I had with so little but
I'll be coming back to that so in case
you haven't watched this yet um seems
like everyone already got Disney Plus so
what do I know
but in case you haven't the Mandalorian
quest in question we do not know the
identity of the implication is we will
never know the identity of it is not
Boba Fett it is some other Mandalorian
um it said early on is it true that you
never take off your helmets and the few
times that it's even proposed made clear
yeah he's not gonna do that so it does
seem very clear at least to be setting
off that we're never gonna see this face
so the the setup for not Boba Fett the
series is that he's a bounty hunter hey
just like that other guy who's dead and
isn't him yeah I'll stop harping on that
I actually don't really care all that
much I always thought Boba Fett looked
cool but I never really cared about him
all that much either I didn't even
really know that was his name when I was
watching the the series as a kid you
know the original films because connolly
says it offhandedly in the in the third
film and in the second he's just the
bounty hunter anyway I'm tangent already
so we have a Mandalorian he's a bounty
hunter we get to see him on the job
doing his thing it is established that
this is set between Return of the Jedi
and presumably before we get to force
awakens because he states early on the
Empire is no more but there's no mention
of the first order or anything like that
so one would assume that we're kind of
in the lull in between the end of the
Empire and the rise of the first order
so that's where we appear to be timeline
wise we jump around to a couple of
planets he gets hired for a bounty that
is it's a special job that's being done
a little bit outside of the normal means
the pay is very high and yeah we get to
see him go about what he needs to do in
order to get there find out what the
bounty is and then once we see what the
value is that's basically our setup for
what I presume is gonna be the rest of
the series so I am gonna start getting
into spoilers a little bit later but I'm
gonna end up I normally I try and save
my complaints for later on but I love
the complaints I'm going to make aren't
really spoilers or if they are they're
spoilers for like tiny things that
aren't plot relevant so there's a lot of
little things about this that just annoy
me and this is me fully copping to the
fact that none of this stuff I am about
to complain about none of it matters not
a bit is none of it impacts the plot I
might be the only one who cares this is
pedantic and nitpicky and dumb but it
all still bugs me so I'm going to
mention it so when I talked about the
trailer for the
thing before I did mention it worked me
that he that the mandalorian is using
Carbonite basically for everybody and
that bugged me because in Empire Strikes
Back it was made clear that the carbon I
freeze is not meant for human transport
and it's super dangerous but given that
this is set later on I'd be willing to
buy that they have fine-tuned it so that
it works as standard Bounty Hunter
procedure enough times passed and it
worked that first time sure cool so I'll
let that one go but there are a lot of
other little things that just kind of
annoy me and again there's nothing wrong
with them but they just perk me so the
first planet we started out on it's an
ice planet I don't think it ever gets
named and there's a speeder on it like
the kind that were on Tatooine and that
immediately bugged me now there's no
reason that there can't be a speeder
there but in my head I had always kind
of assumed and thought and it didn't
even occur to me that I assumed this
until I saw that speeder on on this
planet on this ice planet and go that's
the tattoo me speeder was that doing
there and realized that this is an
assumption I've always had that the
technology is regional that the plant
that different planets are going to
build the technology that they need to
get by in their environment and that
because Star Wars has always had that
very cobbled together feel well I guess
with the exception of some of the
prequels because that was you know in
the Republic when it was all nicer and
shiny but the Star Wars that I love and
that this is very much trying to evoke
has always had that very cobbled
together
feel so the idea that speeders are some
sort of standard transport that exists
on multiple planets that bothered me
like right off the bat I'm like no like
it could be the same principle but it
shouldn't look like the same model that
Luke had on Tatooine and yes you could
they were like obviously it's like it's
a beat-up thing and
come from every anywhere baguette yeah
but who would have moved that offworld
from one place to another and then that
brings me to my original case why is it
so specifically that thing in both
places again there can be a reason maybe
there's a big interstellar Ford company
for lack of a better term that just
pumps these things out and sells them
all over the place I could buy that
that's totally feasible but for me it's
annoying because it starts to make the
planets interchangeable they start to
lose some of their unique flavor when
the technology and what goes on there
doesn't feel as unique to that location
and this is actually kind of starting to
become an issue in general I mean jakku
felt an awful lot like Tatooine even
beyond the fact that they were both
desert planets and that's starting to
bother me because I really wish that
there was less standardization and like
I don't think that's impossible to do I
mean just look at the look at the
Mandalorian ship it's not slave one but
it's somewhat evocative of slave 1 so
why can't you have a land speeder that
is not the Tatooine speeder but it's
somewhat evocative of it I'm spending
too much time on this let's get on to my
other nitpicks which I'm sure I'll also
spend too much time on there was a lot
of hey remember this moments now to the
show's credit it doesn't linger on them
and it doesn't stop the story to have
them but it does have a fairly large
number of them and again it made
instances where what it was calling back
to now feels less unique than it did
before so like for example um we see I
don't know what the species is but
whatever salacious crumb the little
cackling pet that job I has in Return of
the Jedi we see one of those in a cage
and that threw me off because I like I
accept salacious crumb wasn't truly
unique like there had to be others of
that species but like the idea that it's
a standard pet as opposed to this weird
thing that really only job I has and you
know that and no one else would ever
have this thing in their home that was I
it's an assumption that I made that I
didn't realize I made until I saw this
thing caged and I'm like somebody's just
gonna buy it
somebody just gotta have like this
little thing in the corner and the cages
there how I'm going oh what is that
or this one really annoyed me just like
in Jabba's palace and this might
actually have been on Tatooine again I
don't think they named the planet so
I'll accept that it's possible to have a
repeat it but they have the the the ball
on the stick come out you know to
basically interrogate somebody before
they open the door it's fine that they
have that cuz again I'm pretty sure it
was Tatooine so same technology same
planet cool but though it's dialogue and
boy this huh this proves how much I
watched the original Star Wars films way
too much but the things that it says are
identical two lines that the one at
Jabba's palace said and that also annoys
me because one of the nice things about
the droids and the technology in Star
Wars as a universe is that they have
personalities and by having this thing
say the exact same lines which I'm sure
was done simply just to make it uh oh
the fans will be really happy when they
recognize these lines and maybe some of
some fans are or were I'm annoyed
because now I'm suddenly going oh that
thing didn't have like a cool somewhat
antagonistic personality at Jabba's
palace like I thought I did
its standard programmed responses oh
that thing's less interesting now and
you know there there are a few other
things like that small things like that
that are kind of dotted across this that
bugged me but to start to get into some
other stuff including some stuff that I
liked and what my thought is about once
we actually get to the proper set up of
where this thing loos gonna go that
requires getting into spoilers so that's
your warning okay so
first off we get sort of the final
assault with him with Mandalorian going
to this compound to get his bounty head
and we run into I don't know if it is
actually ig-88 it could just be a droid
of the same model but I'm I'm prepared
to roll with that because this this sort
of bounty droid would appear just about
anywhere even if it isn't exactly idat
and it is only the same model that makes
sense cuz bounty hunters jump all over
the place so unlike say the land speeder
that didn't that didn't bother me so
much and it was very cool to see how
that thing operated it's a badass
seriously that thing was not messing
around and so that was very cool I like
I just I just like that Verner Hertzog
is in this like what like a very spotty
with the trailer going wait a minute
what huh and yeah that was it yeah that
was cool to see ya dug it so I like that
the acting is good this this whole thing
looks good it is a good looking show now
when we get to the end and what the
Mandalorian finds that he was sent to
terminate is basically a baby Yoda and I
am slightly mixed feelings about that
specifically but then that gets to what
it looks like it's setting up for the
thing overall so that's specifically it
feels like they're trying to get us
invested because it's a baby version of
a character we already love and that
just just seems like a very cheap way to
tug at the heartstrings I'm fine with
the fact that it's like an infant I kind
of wish that it wasn't necessarily
something's again that feels very
cynically designed to tug at the
existing fan heartstrings just like it
felt very cynical you know the callbacks
to the Carbonite and salacious crumb and
the land speeder and and all the other
stuff I mentioned that annoyed me that
being said this basically sets us up for
a lone wolfing
Hubb situation where the bounty hunter
not meaning to but because he has just a
little too much of his conscience for
his own good is now responsible to
protect this little thing against all
the things that are out there to kill it
and that's a solid enough set up and
it's the kind of story that I think the
Star Wars universe supports very well
I've been somewhat irritated with with
the the films or at you know what little
of the extra material I've read because
I feel like they really need to expand
out what Star Wars stories can be or at
least what stories set in the Star Wars
universe can be because they keep coming
back to Jedi and smugglers and you know
the it's it's the same handful of things
now granted bounty hunters aren't
exactly new this isn't like a really
truly carving a new path but setting up
this kind of story the sort of Ronan's
story that's different that's a little
new I can dig it especially if we're
gonna lean into the more sort of Wild
West vibe that settings like Tatooine
and Jack who have which is a great
setting for that kind of story so as
much as I have nitpick to this thing and
that stuff really does bug me again
disproportionately so I'm sure but it
does and I'm pretty sure if I continue
to watch this and I'll stick with it for
at least a few more episodes and if I
continue to watch it that stuff is going
to continue to bother me
but it's well paced as well act it's
well shot actions good solid set up for
series yeah yeah I'll stick around for
at least a bit so I don't love it I'm
not blown away by it
as is typical of me I have notes but
yeah okay the Mandalorian first episode
you've seen it what you think about it
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about a bunch of stuff to do down
there is
well like subscribe support me on
patreon if you are able to do so that is
an immense help failing that you can
always share the video that's a big help
for me as well
plus there's other links to other stuff
down there besides click on stuff it'll
take you places or don't you don't have
to and the day folks you're the council
I'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]